[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello chat how's everyone doing today
and we are joined by a wonderful Chris
Pratt historical video game nerd
extraordinaire who's going to be taking
us through mountain blade as a little as
a little baby how you doing Chris I am
doing well thank you thank you for the
introduction oh trying to catch the
stream over here oh you know I realized
immediately is that your setup looks so
much even in these small windows your
setup looks like legit you've got like a
red light behind you you be like you
know how to talk about video games like
I've got a boiler well at least I've got
hot water I'm sorry I'm once it I'm
gonna between Jessica Oh God alright
well Chris does that how is it how is
everyone doing chat you're good and
right yeah that's perfect mate
absolutely wonderful
doctor doctor who good you you wave a
Hufflepuff scarf Duke I don't know why
so many people asking for mafia you can
see a Viking on the screen unless 2k has
changed some things with playing banner
oh yeah I guess yeah well you get
started whenever you're ready my friend
this is this is your show so you got
everything Mountain blade as as the the
type of the stream suggests as a baby
which comes from the fact that when the
game first came out in or the access are
really weird burgers one of the weirdest
bugs I've seen in which on the character
creation screen if you press like on
your keyboard you'll try to just turned
into a baby like I really I have no
understanding is why that that was the
case unfortunately that's been patched
out of the game but of course modders
migrate that's my favorite people look
at this chest hair by the way
have you seen this character it's cream
before honest endless
just looks like me except for the
six-pack replace the six-pack with a
beer belly and then it's about the same
and your your underpants like potato bag
yeah it doesn't really matter what I
would character looks like at this stage
actually cuz we're going to change them
once we get into the game so I'll just
go through here I guess we can pick some
things here that are gonna make us good
at fighting that's probably the most
exciting way to stream right people like
yeah people like a big big baby scrap
yeah so our baby Lord that's what we
should make sure they called the stream
I feel like it'd be nice to be good
where's let's see riding and pole on
that sounds good to you you know you've
done this before I've only played a few
campaigns and then I've played a bit of
multiplayer right yeah did you like it
yeah yeah I've been really enjoying it
um the way I play melts players I put
like Sabaton on really Swedish battle
music and then just but cavalry charge
everything Mustafa how you doing my
friend mark kill Kerwin called you a
true gamer strap strap something with
your old old title right when I worked
it yeah when you're a gamer which is the
job I do now for some reason I guess
because very few people you'll notice
they're very few people in the UK games
media have they're elevated in
cerebellum that's needed and so often in
fact you and I would end up going to a
lot of the same yeah I think we've seen
each other more total war events than we
have any other location I basically made
my character good swinging a two-handed
weapon
happy days you guys inch an era enjoying
what you're watching be sure to check
out our donation links we're raising
money for a good cause a couple of good
causes
even if
swinging battle-axes as a babies very
silly we're raising things were things
that very serious if you can check them
out click the links and ignore our our
bumbling we're doing our best
despite iteration rock is a baby I can't
believe I want to say by the way like a
huge congratulations to you and the rest
of the games what teams are running this
thing like it's not is it pound first
would you like kicked off and we've been
doing a we well now yeah yeah that's
over a month on this there's been
amazing people in it so very impressed
oh my god this guy's face okay
mentally I adore but it is quite junkie
at times it does look like all the
people in man blade have been grown from
the same fungus he's so he's so intense
this is our brother by the way I don't
think gonna have much to do with him in
this stream but like imagine that wish
your brother imagine that's how your
brother looked into your eyes days
that's a yes with guns and quickly oh so
by the way you might have noticed I call
that character boss because I want to
call a family should know scene right
now
not very baby like yet anyway whatever
is the most baby like so think about
this in my mind I don't know why I like
apples apples as like yeah that's quite
childlike fruit i iphone as a soup ladle
I mean it probably is meant to be like
think outside of the medieval box here I
mean the basic the basic star shapes are
very baby as well
oh yeah like just a stone yeah yeah it
looks like one of those block puzzles
that you trying to fit a square in a
circle hole okay that's cute yeah
nice very wholesome okay so for those
who haven't played mountain blades - I
feel like I said this a lot about the
original those impressions can be a
little a little weird if you haven't
sleep before but it's basically again in
which you a medieval RPG in which you
recruit local peasants and ride around
having fights with people until those
peasants turn into warriors and you have
yourself an army and that basic premise
is enough if you click with this game
you play it for like 200 hours and never
leave that hundred percent it's um
it's so bizarre as well some of the
things that you end up doing so I
thought to begin with before we go
straight into baby mode I could just
show you what a normal battle is meant
to look like like we are this we can
have a scrap with these looters over
here is you're on the Twitter one but I
believe in you
yeah actually what we like in our it was
- a sword a shield and a spear and a
horse I think we can do two to one with
okay stream next it's the it's when you
finish a conversation and there's like a
freeze frame and they're all just
scowling at you even worse when you
capture an enemy general and you're like
I'm gonna execute you and this is face
that it pauses on it's horrendous
yeah that's a lot of that so right I'll
quickly introduce these are the boys
that we've just hired likes to like
their hearts over their heads now that's
real recruits
and then these guys are going to just
start attacking a straightaway so I
might actually need trained see if we
can will it's just the girls and stones
though he just threw a stone at your
horse's head yeah oh god actually you
know what I was quite brave with this
fight I'm starting to think no bunch of
runnin I know but like at certain point
a certain number of rocks becomes a
problem Dave alright the fact we've got
a horse that's that's the one thing that
we currently letting it get absolutely
turned to blue there but so this yeah
that is basically the initial premise of
unalloyed he's men are covered in blood
I'm so happy to be here he's loving life
yeah so yeah you'll get in a few fights
you hire more people you avenge you have
to find ways to keep like paying for
your army it's a really good game for
the actually the you you want to hire
more people all the time so that you can
actually do more impressive things like
sieges and weather but the more people
that you employ the more expensive it is
to like keep your your group going and
you have to film them as well yeah and
it's just everything just gets really
expensive and so you end up having to do
more and more fights basically just to
fund this like legitimate army that you
just built and over the inventory full
of butter yeah all right yeah well pay a
couple of chunks wheels they look like
beans okay sure I don't know why but
they look saying the same is cheese it's
just it's just you get a lump of
unconstitu Adair ian in van inaud okay
so you just saw a fights there Dave
which was like traditional start to
mount and blade I actually think I did
pretty well than when a donor brag when
you kill my guys that had stones sure
and we did we didn't lose a single
person at one of them can now be
upgraded to even infantryman or hostile
banana surely well I usually like to get
a like a few lads with shields first oh
yeah there enough building around that
like so you've got like a core cuz right
now these guys are just like it's just
that he's just gonna stand that and even
rocks are gonna be a problem one man a
field wall yeah so he won't like if just
having a shield on its own is like a
huge advantage however I did promise
that we would be playing this game
slightly differently yeah the boss
doesn't look very baby like right now he
doesn't thankfully because of a mod I
have installed called
detailed character creation
I can actually do a little bit more than
usual like head depth for example I
don't think that's usually a thing that
I get to play around no wait forearm I
don't know I don't think have the
authority to talk about muscles make no
anyway the important one is this one
here which is age that's not usually
something you get to do anything with in
the base game you can Oh God you saw get
this is fates as well faces old bodies
these it's a bit like the when he sits
from the wrong chalice and Indiana Jones
rapidly however you can also go the
other way this bar the last few inches
nothing happens over here
hey how he goes so smooth yeah so I can
tell myself into for that zoom in yes I
should have warned you about that
yes Wow interestingly the baby can have
the same options with hey that was
delightful that's that that's Chuckie
you've made yo God isn't it but no no
facial hair unfortunately alright I
wonder for a bald baby but like the fact
that there are some options here is
exciting we're gonna that's that's the
one
reckon yeah we're gonna end up with a
helmet on anyway are we well I think the
thing is about playing as a baby well
you'll see
yes also some other options that if I
wanted to I think I I think I like how
it is but I could cover my face in like
war pain the baby
sure it seems a bit aggressive for boss
baby you know boss babies here to to
store a an empire sure but he doesn't
want to he wants to make a few friends
along the way
keep his face as its if anything boss
baby's going to scare people into
donating they're gonna donate in the
links below for this to stop I scaled up
to fit the horse not correctly like is
so massive anyway is running from boss
baby's party yeah you wouldn't you go
ahead that you could land a battleship
on so what I did I just have a bunch
more portraits look the spear yeah
Bishop the thing that you want to see in
action is the shield because it doesn't
scale down with the baby would sing with
baby this is the hippo exchange yes oh
wow actually the the bigger thing with
this in fact is that first I think
certainly happened when when it got a
shot of the game but actually when you
play as a baby you're basically in
venerable as far as I can tell
any horizontal attack is just gonna go
over your head Shirley yeah I actually
think I think wasn't that baby's face is
portrayed in the the voice the voice
changes oh wow infantry look at the
shields by the way let's take my entire
body the lads a little alarmed by what's
happened somebody said there's many who
I've large doors whose ring a bell
anyway as I if I can as well I think I
think it basically makes me immune to
yeah makes me immune to damage notice
you just lost a chunk of health oh good
Wow okay is he just if the hitbox is
weird I'm guessing the hitbox is just so
small of a struggling to hit you
okay so basically boss baby is sort of I
think at this stage plus baby can pretty
much take on like an entire siege by
himself I mean that's the goal then
right yeah I think we'll try it but yeah
it's the lads over there who well we'll
get more involved in the fight I don't
want to it's like have a priest or
everyone oh I need like an army to build
up just for you know respect if these
guys they will ensure beginning we
didn't know what to make of me hit your
five dads the professor once he's
enjoying Battaglia I don't know it does
Betania let's suit the baby lifestyle if
anything I think powerful enough to
start your own plan yeah like I can
pretty much water it's just the face of
the baby the main like the the Hardy ice
folk never every faction in mountain
blade kinda has an archetype right like
a recognizable he's got the Romans and
type of Mongols in the east and the West
Indies yeah that's right
I think this is around the time that
like the it's like muddled after when
the Roman Empire was like falling apart
so these are actually like different
competing factions within that Barney
and then these are like the these are
like your typical Knights like who
actually ended up being a bit lame if
you speak to the king I'm not sure who
this year oh if maybe bus baby is so big
or so small that it's not something me
to worry about he's too big for any
other clan I think now carrying too much
loot after basically I guess boss baby
himself isn't gonna be able to carry a
little or shouldn't get ya know shoddy
correct so I don't think we need to we
could put a tattered cloth on a head but
I actually like the haircut so
that you know what yeah 100% agree
I wonder if something we might want to
do early on is like let's attack that
114 are we yeah I'm fine
hi quick save please in there I could do
that and I think we would win but it
would take so long at the moment but I
could do it alright well we'll build up
to that I'm thinking well we'll do this
for a while we'll see how chat feels but
we I think you may be switching it up to
some multiplayer after this we'll see
how the adventures of boss baby go yeah
gonna see to castle then patrons in the
chat there so I'm putting out that there
is always will there's no respect to be
had when you're the boss baby only fear
you either rule as a respected ruler or
you're feeling
oh no I didn't need to go to the tavern
whoops you're in the range of mate you
can't come in here where's your ID this
is how I felt
trying to get served in a bar so I would
say the first 25 years of my life it was
pretty much this like one beer please
that's a cursed image it's the game is
is trying to hold its own against this
the more you turn your head did more
dystonia because I did want to have a
look if there's any weapons I might want
to buy oh I see why I tell you what I
want to have a lookout for they haven't
gone here but a nice safe I feel like
bus baby kids could work with it safe
for now there's a sickle that's like
halfway there that's just a rubbish safe
and if you don't know that okay
just the arena have anything going on
enter
and there's no tournament tournament
you'd be able to rock yeah we'll be
definitely doing on those let me tell
you if this what you mean well this is
awful this is this is the prime of this
young young rulers life you just murder
a man what I wasn't looking oh no it's
that it's the damage I can hear back at
the screen as ice no I'm not I'm not
attacking this it yeah yeah this isn't
way to do it bus baby there'll be a time
in a place all right we'll just hire a
couple of swordsmen and then we'll we'll
pop out and we'll try and earn a little
bit of money so that we can get
ourselves out it would also be nice to
actually I get our boys involved in some
of the fights because I think they only
gain experience if if they themselves
yeah they have to do some swinging I
think yeah so many butts baby will soar
transition now into upper management
[Laughter]
like he's you know he no longer needs to
get his hands dirty
all right ride around for some some
looters for people that haven't played
this game before by the way like I
wouldn't the I'm always interested to
know what people's first impressions and
blade are I think we're playing it in a
very weird way oh yeah I always think
and better in this one than the previous
game but the his sword chokes you in in
the deep end which is fine but also I
don't know if people get the appeal of
the game just from looking at it yeah
it's um like I when I was like kind of
exposed to the game before I started
playing it was like this this is very
bizarre and feels like it's got a lot of
moving parts and then you try it play it
for a while and you and you realize that
you've bitten you like 14 hours into a
campaign you've not eaten dinner yet the
DM the trip cones are quite nice as well
with so like I've got a boy here because
they're gonna be throwing stones as I
can tell everyone to like get their
shields up which is why these these
people need to get upgraded to the three
years I have shields we can I think I
can edit companions using this mod can
leave how would you like to be a sort of
lieutenant
it's lieutenant babies night time so
it's definitely past this kids bedtime
as well maybe that's why post baby start
if this whole endeavor it's like sad
enough Abed times no more bed time under
the rule oh go on let's go on lads no
one escapes when you gonna do if people
make games episode on the baby Maude
towards about about this that when the
glitch happened and I don't think they
were that press with it and they were
like yeah we're gonna get rid of that
now no comment
it's either all another one a weird
glitch like this comes out in a game
either yeah they've been into it or
they're like I we don't even want to
exists when them the weird hit man
briefcase thing what happened with
hitman two I contacted those guys and
they were so excited to talk about it
yeah I've seen the video it's which
that's such a lovely way cuz it that
that glitch in particular is like
similar to the baby thing I guess it's
just like so visibly ridiculous that I
can imagine some some developers might
take that too seriously be like no
hitman is a serious area serious gamers
yeah yeah I think which is anyway we've
we've bashed this guy in the head
our enemy is this looter which means
that we can we do actually have the
option to recruit them into our team
which I I feel like watch baby allows
for second chances also I really enjoy
that right look at this look at this man
right now right now he's an enemy oh no
wait oh no that was gonna be a big
reveal bathe but unfortunately we have
to wait a little bit longer press the
control level mark marks asked if you
can edit everyone to be babies and so I
have a baby army or is it just like
companions not recruits is the baby on
the upgrade tree
unfortunately these these people like
our recruits we just have they haven't
treated to go through but there are like
custom yeah companion characters which
we'll have a look at I'll tell you what
let's treat ourselves to a couple
watches and I'm a big fan of arches I
like I like to gain the system and find
a choke hold a choke point in the map Oh
marches in a few she'll world one one
thing that's really good to do is you've
got cavalry and run a credit Road point
you can get your cavalry to dismount in
front of your arches and then the
impossibly can't get through the horse
wall oh wow okay I thought man you're on
a whole nother level to me it's it's
very much gaming the mechanics but you
can just see them as you're struggling
to get through the big line of horses
that have no cavalry on Dave I'm
currently playing as a baby whose hitbox
is so small no one can actually damage
them so good point well token the spear
clipping into the ground really kind of
breaks perspective yeah I mean oh it's
just it's getting closer towards you
that's all it's bending I want to get
closer to me I want it to be as far as
that's okay yes we what we're starting
to get a few a few people working for us
and I've you that's like 30 quid a day
thereafter unbelievable it's not okay
right I think this is it yeah this is
the pointers from making currently an
enemy day if you see a person that we
don't that usually would fight however
if I press this one button and he/she
changes shape our color that's that's no
okay I mean that's how you showed
allegiance back in noodle times right
different sure just we sorry we need
your shirt to be red otherwise like this
ain't gonna work out for us I think you
can you can do better than losers though
oh yeah I mean yeah that's true I'm just
trying to get quickly get a bit of gold
so I don't accidentally bankrupt myself
in a purse if these men don't want to
follow you into battle that's their
problem
you know what you shouldn't shouldn't
need to pay them they should be paying
you for the privilege of being under the
protection of boss baby exactly we have
the makings of an actual arm you know
like we've got linking feature over here
archers are starting to do at least
something this is what it's all about
for some people watching this that we
let oh my god this game this game I see
it I see it I see the point others
they're gonna be like yes okay boss game
level Congrats
he really doesn't need any levels it's
already max level if anything I want to
make him less powerful nice just show a
few lights there we should do an
incentive every every every keep or
village or castle you take like five
dollars to charity
okay we'll just go then you'll be in
then you like the wholesome scourge of
Vega so that's one of the factions right
I collide Rio am I getting that from
another fantasy game maybe it's it's
it's a very like throw a dart board
fantasy name generator' sort of I don't
really lose that much if you like it
might we what we like we're good at
fighting that's not an issue maybe we
want people to like us a bit more finish
in hacking a little bit more charm hey I
was doomed in the portrait is so good in
in in a game full of cursed image
portraits yeah okay right let's see if
there's
it usually has a let me check oh you got
to do this to check if Chris ends up
taking castles and keeps as a baby I
want to see donations coming in because
this that's smaller easy task
kid kid can't even read yet yeah so
apparently there's a and a tournament
going on in poorest to as poorest you
see poorest it's right in the middle
you're screaming it's the city over oh
my god Oh like this is this is indeed a
mod it was originally a bug but it's
been turned as a mod and salvaged you
need detailed character creation and
then that you also need another mod to
sort of make it work but and with the
devil yes all right okay I'm gonna get
rid of our your size Congrats
yeah my safe you know I don't need any
views with others weapons just yet I'm
gonna commend you all on this site which
is also going quite terribly so this
look like the face of mercy
alright poor us let's have a little go
in a tournament a good way to earn some
renown I sure do you wanted to check out
this site real quick we'll be of these
looters then I promise we'll do a
tournament it reminds me of remember
that old kids film when the baby gets
lost in the city and it's all like
accidentally crawls and I got a good or
over a building or something as I can
hot early 90s film so babes vacation in
this does best bade pig in the sea
baby's day out 1994 what's on us baby
stay o obviously watch watch boss baby
I'm just imagining that I know what that
character is which is quite a big swing
to carry a camera there by the way we've
got we've got our first woman's so we
can bet it all on baby I'm going to win
I'm pretty sure they can't I can't be
beaten
so this might be a nice way to earn some
money get your bets in chat who's who's
your money on team on the scholar
Imperial trained inventory mum if a
vertical slice isn't gonna get you then
nothing will ya team on the scholars
doing the dirty work for you I think is
I don't get my hands dirty until I need
to is it see I've only seen boss baby
knock an enemy out can you kill someone
because you're not doing any damage to
the torso ahead oh so you only have to
disable them oh no I think I think that
happens we've shot weapons tend to kill
and blow weapons down but I think in a
tournament you don't actually kill
anyone because these these characters
exist your first your first looters you
got before the other infantryman wasn't
about dream okay well look at that no
cuz they were part of the reason I think
because I don't think he'll words tell
words really want you to play it's boss
baby so I think they saw unluck made it
in part of the way the weird light side
effect of that is that you can't
actually be damaged so maybe there's
something in but in the fact that the
babies can't actually take human lives I
don't know I don't know your attacks
like also too low for him to block I
think it usually that would be a really
hard fight beating someone like this at
this stage I got almost like a decent
you hit him in like the unarmored ankles
it's your finger stranger moon is like
gaming the system he thinks that we
should be able to invite all the kick
kids in the game and then no one will
grab you soldier are you so am i
something I want to do after this no we
should probably earn some money from
this is maybe I think I can hire the
lieutenant were talking about yeah
how you got back up now you an equity on
your team you still stand I'll stand
here you fight over me mr. garden it's
not that that's the install of this like
that person didn't even register that I
was here it's like behind your kid to
work day something we might want to do
later on
I guess add some element of challenge to
this game that currently has I think I
can at some point on the age scale I
stopped being completely invulnerable to
damage so maybe we can try and find
mystery I remember that when I when I
was growing up I hit my 13th birthday
and I was like I could be stabbed now
few does in feudal times its it 13 years
old practically middle-aged gets sores
in a kite shield off you go you think
you're on a crusade mate see here when
the hem bug is an armor that's a classic
you just swing nice across the shins no
share one one then a versus boss
it will win right after the shins again
it's a classic move for reason I've
completely changed up the sort of arena
meta game there we go you know make a
big cone I don't have a grand a half god
I think we just like quadrupled that
money and got ourselves a really decent
bit moment this game's easy get good
babies look at that wow that does look
killer to fit strange I mean I actually
actually have that manga and I've never
read it read it but if it's exactly how
the streams going that maybe I should
read Wolfen club it's taking damage a
sign of puberty emotional damage
that's how it goes in real life is there
a part when you're playing his boss
favor you ask your first crush out and
she doesn't know and that's the first
time he'll take damage is actually
something like happen in this game by
the way like the trying to boost one in
only boss baby can hurt bus baby
it's like tails world dannis I Dave this
could be you I love it
you're a sort of scullery type I'm
bossing him he was in a fight yeah he
was a sort of that's what attracted me
to him in the first place
yeah mate you you cheap as well 472
that's nothing that's nothing but loss
pay me yes
will he keep his bid because the bids
already on good baby
you're just a tenant baby Oh Dave baby
[Music]
he's still a man Benjamin burned him
into his head it's fine they can my
hat's disintegrate into my head is fine
you don't need to know I had a hat I saw
it just needs a man longbow that's
bigger than him okay well that's
I wonder if you are now also immune
because that's just face my mommy was
the overpowered there's 27 lose yes full
full charge okay sorry boss Davey there
is very good suggestion if not okay the
portrait looks really sad as all of us
don't mind the scythe yeah this so yeah
no this is perfect
if I won't come death destroyer all
right okay
oh I don't know if stand out do I see
right yep
looking good glad you brought your
shield excellent you look a little
concerned there is do you just take down
a desperate leftover damage from and did
the tavern jump attack someone shin see
if you'll kill him now or just harvest
them my army my army your horse is gonna
get killed as well disguised absolutes
schoolyard bully the voice lines one
beef is the legs game gonna go again
again
oh wow bring your kid to war day
absolutely
happy Friday Brandon are you doing
welcome to the very cursed stream cursed
stream for a good cause right
god I how many oh I I lost my my army
but eight of them got knocked out and
yet Dave with seven kills oh you love to
sit goodbye professor have a good day we
need to do that
the Army is starting to look after
itself it's 20 men an army is ha that's
more of a rabble I guess so
we're trying well God is literally two
it's just me and you that's left
standing up Oh is everyone okay knocked
out okay lose lose one something I see
they've seen an easy target there
they've seen two babies riding along
actually you don't have a horse
I didn't two pair of ankle biters
Sanders's seen one baby riding along one
baby walking and they thought you know
what we can have them miraculously
survive all over I'm like I'm like
wearing the hair that you're missing
yeah between us the whole head of hair
in a hole man go on Dave I'll let you
suffered of up
be like anime jump yeah I know it's I
think it's basically the exact same size
jump as if you were a full human man and
again again I've taken a morale penny
the enemy of fleeing yeah the smart ones
would known as well people are starting
to take notice you heard about a murder
and baby rockin around brighter I think
you read about I said I don't have
wrists ending goes in like I think you
all will lose the immunity they won't
understand understand that we've broken
it okay well I'll quickly get away from
from these likely lads it's now at this
stage it's embarrassing to still be
fighting looters yeah I think I think
we've proved that destined for bad
things take over that's why you're my
tenant if you take over cast you have to
hire a third baby to be the castle so
you it's after it come back and there's
just nap rooms that have been built
without your permission
all right back to poor us old trusty
poor us the nice thing about this game
by the way is that you can see like a
bunch of these slots or empty is to kiss
like the game the game sort of plays
itself without you it doesn't really
care if you're a baby or if you're even
here like its own characters are running
around recruiting people doing similar
versions what you're doing as he purrs
all grown people yeah that being a key
difference I don't actually know if you
run into an II don't think there are any
babies in the game already even like
maybe there are teenagers actually you
can have children yeah I think if you
like go into town sometimes you can see
that peasants walk around and some
then we'll be yeah like teammates come
on knocking not babbys do you want a
horse Dave I can give me give me the
mule you want in your haircut and then
let me just quickly buy some food so
some milk Sean oh that's unfortunate not
an option is it baby eats her lips I
didn't like him
you're not like olives I was a gross
okay I apply it all right I think that's
the two portraits of the top just oh in
a play screen hey can you can you talk
to me click the conversate button
converse a conversation oh there is a
human oh wow you looking quite pleased
with yourself are you
yeah he's the face of a bloodthirsty
position in the clamp I tell you what
you eat like a trusty a trusty sword
you're now the surgeon great group some
folks gonna get amputated gangrenous
legs all right
she weak out of this little corner of
the world and see ya he was there for us
I'll recruit some people in the way so
you can build up at least I'll get
knocked out as you take on castle
doesn't leave yeah but it's good to at
least show up with some numbers so
people think you seriously just hiring a
line of cheered is really just
supporting over the back don't you dare
given my my mule you'd have to kill him
all right I don't think I've given you
your mule yet
whoops can I do that oh it's not wait
until is it on earlier
yeah they've got no saddle I've got a
riding Bentley just charge that's in you
know you can overthink these things yeah
I'm sure we'll be fine against the
unwashed masses that have levels of
weapons now that we've got like your
character is also like invulnerable sure
I could maybe try
so I guess actually no let's try it
let's try one massive bow let's like do
something there is ridiculous and then
maybe else I'll I'll transition us baby
into a sort of later years the horse
again could actually be injured I just
don't need this I don't need this like I
know you think this is a big fight for
you for you lights but really like
you're just getting in the way and also
are they in telling to Lou like the
scholastic books catalog where Steve no
faith oh you're a unit separate you're
in a separate category you know because
you know infantry you actually you're
technically cavalry against that so
you've been weighing in the reserves
whilst literally everyone else got
butchered on my saddle this donkey you
sent him over there
I told charge I think he's just gonna go
by just guys that mule does not help I
mean I don't think anything can damage
the Army's image problem at this point
you've got like a mini Genghis Khan just
chopping everyone's ankles off
all right god I didn't feel good about
that right I just didn't
uh-huh my heart wasn't in it and yeah I
still had to slow to the 17 minute
no good deed I'm running into some Oh
everyone's wounded they can't carry
stuff yeah it's kids only me and you
like carrying things which is just
causing these issues okay I'll get over
to this castle over here oh my god so
slowly we have to take some steps we
don't need all these hammers first start
throw-in a merfolk oh I do that we might
have some come on nah intimidated them
enough yeah well you told my time this
is a dream not a nightmare
this is blessed blessed content all
right slowly the led to waking up here
we go and they're starting to carry some
of these hammers smack okay cheers boys
anyway yeah really sorry about that fire
and the other one and the one before
that okay well just hire some people at
this stage just to carry things for us
and then let's just get some horses
involved yes if you get horses they you
can pack those as they pack right it's
kind of ridiculous like get me a sample
as well ma'am
do you actually know just want my mule
treated right so he wants my harness my
anything do half barding for three grand
leave like let me see let me let me sell
these hammers first hopefully that all
right I've got thousand quid there it's
not it's gonna have to be a cheap saddle
I'm sorry like I I just I'm not many of
money that's fine yeah it's better it's
better than just you know writing rough
like that I know I said I'm not made of
money but you know what we have got an
image problem having me so maybe it may
be a good way to sort out we just we
Lulla laughs very suave I don't need
these tattered arm wraps that's holding
me back I feel like even with them with
the side he need like black robes like a
little mini oh oh I'm not sure um I know
it's always right hand on we need some
lads with holding shields that still
issue that's good now yes that's the
issue okay
I'll round up a few more boys and then
we'll we'll go for a big scrap yeah
sounds good I think this huge might be a
bit ridiculous cos that would sort of
like it's not that we wouldn't win I'm
certain you would win the thing is see
just take ages to set up if you don't
have many men as well right like an
engineer you need to like usually like
kill about 500 people and then that's
gonna be an issue if it's just me in you
you know like Sam Sam Nam of the 63 lads
I think he's a he's a target oh yeah
Sam nan he looks independent as well oh
yeah he's legion of the betrayed so I
think that's like a mercenary out here
Reid okay kinda mercenaries okay he's
not running out clear he doesn't know
what's going yeah very very slow is that
because you're carrying a mr. got we do
all the habits I just what speed we
actually are here oh no it's a pretty
normal speed I think we just haven't got
we still have mostly infantry alright
alright although I on Anna's bow wearing
that bear oh I tell you what that's a
good bit okay I am boss and who are you
you take do not believe we have any
quarrel with you none
deliver stars you know it just feels
like I agree that we should we should
attack in but like we haven't said a lot
to him before it happened I guess you
know may-maybe boss baby doesn't know
many words yet you know mum dad
I surrender or die okay so the odds not
currently in our favor
yeah no cares about power levels Semin
has the look of a man that's just been
attacked by it an army led by a baby and
all right easy I pick a chart we can try
and just like everyone in shape all
right Dave if you wouldn't mind just
going over there our one Archer didn't
you didn't even give me my bad and may
look meals naked if you do miss fight I
tell you what there's actually quite a
lot of them Dave if you could go and
just so you want to send the rest
they're not invincible they're not
actual living God's my one Archer here
really trained his best I'm not sure
about this accomplished
we hope that they're all just swarming
around us gone I'm in the fray you could
just see that I like on holy crap
best so well armed it is so well armed
if look at lead shield how how is the
archer missing this actually might be a
mistake and snare you got this
well we've got it but like it's just oh
Jesus Christ
like a fool you know principies so much
Jesus they've got massive shields like
they've adapted you know the archers
took someone else
no kill yet try vehicle attacks there
the leaving hey yeah that's it okay so
yeah jump vertical God the shields was
seen took out the general the morale
will be faltering any minute oh god I
feel really bad about this I've been
watching some of the playful streams and
they've had such a nice vibe 2.oh meets
people coming together like community
spirit you've had like like kind of
funny on and my famous voice actors got
a strategy King on right now and is -
baby it's are you still going in your
own lucky you I think so I'm just in
that word yeah I'm taking principles out
have you actually yeah yeah low work I
tell you what if we work together there
might be some impacts I can sort of
swing around and oh you like slightly
and then all of a sudden II just
surrounded and stuck that's the trick I
need to not get surrounded by literally
everyone this is just their rear echelon
just watching this unreal have you seen
the state of my clothes my new roads
crimson okay I I think after this by I'm
gonna have to age bus baby like the
emotional toil of what just happened
haha I'm you takin some effect
I think how many prisoners and loot
we're gonna have after this oh my god
yeah like this is like high level looped
as well you're not meant to have a fight
like this until 20 hours running let's
oh you broken their spirits this is a
full hour as as a tactical retreat you
just got me charge again oh is that the
group no that's just a tree Rea the
leader of the group went down first the
arch of the head shine oh I think so sit
on the sidelines here never in the back
well the babies did the hard work what
cost
we're too small to even can see through
the grass Jesus Christ oh yeah I think
they're just falling back oh there's an
odd river that might be through hasn't
that's our our chair oh yeah hit the
edge of the map so it looks like they're
going if you look at the power bar at
top all right I can use happened to wait
oh because it was so imbalance about you
having to wait think so cuz they'll
still be an army on the map oh that this
sounds like victory music where is this
fight yeah the fights still going on
somewhere Jesus I just feel I feel bad
about that one again like the novelty of
Bob's baby has started to wear off and
it's been replaced by just guilt it's
real what hath Elroy caught there we
gonna fight look I mean the power bar
has shifted somewhat okay we should have
this on numbers learn known well if you
took Bob if you took the babies at the
equation I I think even good units like
if you get surrounded that's true
sorry oh no that was mine as well I just
thought I saw someone well unless I was
like yep you'll do the blood lust
overtook Jesus can't wait to see the loo
oh yeah there's just some good salts we
lost no 101 we see 16 kills 11 knockouts
and 35 retreated spots baby take
business yes one of them being wounded
Oh
mainly I can't recruit these yet because
there is a certain skill tree you need
to go down but that would be ridiculous
and sell them for your cash time I think
he might scaled it to my level maybe or
just that the ones we killed were I mean
that rusty mace is still 900 gold so I
vote my harness now as well by the way
put my mule up just give us baby some
more charm a lot more direct the terror
okay boss Davey baby
yes everyone works our clan names baby
so it'd be David baby we're not gonna
speak to you Dave is snotty-nosed Booga
Oh baby baby that works into it I've
been called worse okay see something you
never had anything that wasn't just this
very cheap sword as well yeah okay hey
yo come on you'll absolutely pimped our
control wait wait can the Sheep fit in
the cavalry slot
you I think we have to I don't know
that's that's unacceptable you have a
massive oh my god oh my god yep I guess
she may as well have that message there
being fewer peelers to throw as well you
can have that coped Oh actually know
what sorry I need the code because I'm
about to oh god sorry sorry safe they
taking this on the free laughs I'm gonna
leave you as the venerable and von Raab
a V but maybe it's time for the actual
boss maybe to at least have some kind of
difficult to contend with gravel well
while you're continuing to curse this
whatever we're watching I'm gonna skip
out and get some more water and then
maybe after it another battle and maybe
you can do some multiplayer and take the
fight to real human beings so I will
ruin myself on this though no cuz I'm so
used to not having to fight Oh that'll
be a good experiment then I shall return
momentarily and you look after chat for
us boom love you okay so I think I have
to just crush the threshold into beating
idol and then I can oh wow I don't think
I got quite to that level I think like
somewhere like
I don't know I think like something like
that might do it
should I give that girl I need to
actually wear some mama though for when
they do that because despite what this
scam has told you so far we're not
actually equipped to do the kind of
flights we've been doing alright so bus
may be sort of grown up a little bit
this is the the later years in his
professional military career he's seen
some things and it is taking a toll in
fact we can really use it as actually if
you get hit on the head right now that's
that's not great for us alright I might
head to somewhere nearby this one and
we'll see we'll see if we can actually
get this game out like it was meant to
be played in fact I might just give this
a quick go to see very very quickly if
if I can notate damage oh god stop stop
stop
hello
so I have to make myself throw up quite
a lot you know I think that's enough
like I actually should be a normal unit
in this game for once actually no I
leave the light over here and I'm just
going up like who are you fine more
Loomis yeah I mean I just wanted to tell
ya no I can't get hurt I can't get hurt
Oh No so that's what this game is
actually yes rather brutal no um you
just watch at this point oh yeah I just
meant like I said can I tell I won't get
stuck in which oh my god I think yeah I
think the default is whenever the
general dies they all default to charge
prisoners get those sold somewhere that
was embarrassing that like immediately
once I think the game on yeah well I'll
make sure my band was ready and you know
buy some sieges I think the seizures are
some of the most fun parts yeah
no no two clicks of a button will be
ready to go cool well it's no longer
boss baby now is Easy's boss yeah it
doesn't feel right it's like this at
this point I'm just playing a fellow
with a dodgy heck running around with
his son Dave drunk off his previous
burglaries and really not you like it
anymore
we jump into yeah and do that all right
yeah [ __ ] over cool yeah when was the
last time you played man blade yeah it's
been a little while since I played man
played actually um it was it was the
last big update they had oh I should
wait do I need to because I was running
this off a mod launcher do I need to
relaunch it so your project you put me
into egg here you'll need to exit it and
then when you start it through Steam
you'll get a little them like
multiplayer every single player thing
you know that stuff that go and I had
before that I know I can see it don't
you worry I took care of you unless
unless you want me to that's a very
fetching background yeah I mean it was
its they don't know that I do a youtube
series channel thing people a games and
no mess with you I thought I'd put a
funny desktop background whilst I was
talking and then I said god I needed to
change that with one else we're good
I think you saved me all right the save
yourself being too red in the face nice
kid okay yeah once it says you're in bad
Lord I can invite you and we'll take
place so it's gonna be on your screen
yeah yeah so you can exit parsec and
we'll go on my screen I'm not sure
there's any silencing let's play though
yeah no I don't think they will play
works quite differently to what you've
just seen it works like it should
yep
which which mode do you want to do you
think you can see by doing we can try a
few different ones I think the siege
vessel would be firm just accused of the
spectacle of it is if people haven't
seen that before that is just excellent
yeah it is it is the most like kind of
epic set PC sort of watch I don't fight
you through Steam on the lobby you can
you're paying offline so that's why my
god you have not been online in two
months
yeah it's because I am sometimes placed
if that's pretty release and then yeah
one time I was playing I guess the ex
country review and then steam had
recently rolled out like the fact that
people new friends this can just view
your game what you're playing
and yeah you got careful when you do
that we've review build up some things
have been a cool town similar good let's
just skip over that that's fine let's go
right can how do I invite you now all
right yeah whatever works it's not pop
enough for me
there is and then ya see do a bit of a
ceaseless 60 versus versus 60 play
account hell yeah
is one of the more epic
yeah like siege experiences I think you
can have it's well well I kind of brat
purposes that miss labor and chat make
sure you're checking out those links the
left of our lovely faces raising money
for a good cause
with through the medium of very cursed
babies well then because the last I play
the money play was pretty hop in it's
got it's got a dedicated multiplayer
scene that's for sure yeah a huge one
yeah I played it since the place since
yeah because the serious we is a lot of
players we might have to wait for the
games for people to enter the pool yeah
I've had before where it takes it can
take a few minutes to get into a a game
but then once you're in it like stay in
it really
Marja says
give away a is a thing topic the steam
pot oh I did idea that was yay you're a
good mystery yes I've given way it was
either here's the thing even the games
or in captain mode ah yes so that means
you you have a group of units that
follow you all right yeah you you're in
charge of a few chaps that gonna be a
bit intense siege then they said this
isn't a siege a seizure whirlwind with
the sequence it was a different game
mode I think yeah well do captain mode F
okay I don't know how balanced our team
is so yeah although Knights I respect it
um I'm just like the normal sergeants
with some maces and throwing axes oh
look at that be a good front light oh I
am gonna be now oh yeah seven nights or
23 that's the thing with peasant leve
they're just gonna drop ya and I go for
sergeants yeah that's yes
oh I'll ride around with some fun guard
and then be heroic respect it come into
it try and remember how to get people to
follow me one two
then f1 also lets you pick some house
we've got like so many sergeant's yeah I
have found the infantry which shields I
don't actually know which one is right
yeah there's a lot of them on the hill
so they've taken we have to capture
flags in this as well right into the
middle into the fray are you what about
these plain guards they don't have any
shields do they who's got big two Spears
oh that's you in middle yeah I was gonna
can't help him then I saw some of the
lights from the corner huge charge oh
yeah
no they're already on the retreat I'm
never scared I'm in the middle I'm on be
flag okay I'm getting in amongst all
these arches
I think we've I've gone into their
version of a peasant levy
I've been slicing get the savages yeah
we've got we've got them on numbers but
we need to get our flags as well get the
B flag we've taken we've got that he'll
know I'm in the middle on B flag
oh yeah they have still got some Latin
reserve and they are coming for beef
like oh my oh my this is gonna get
stinky is that you who just charge into
shield-wall know you learn nothing from
terrible we might be losing people my my
sergeants have been routed all of them
yeah we we got flanked on be flogged
only right my guy hum has all of his
units though I don't know if you told
the reserve on purpose oh I don't think
you realize the only took out the horse
there's a spare horse over there have it
yes if there's only two players left on
our team against or for the enemy
[Music]
best of luck tear that guy's comebacks
on now that's the clip
I was going to jump the horse over them
good this guy's attack in his own labs
right try to back out and get us into a
seizure and that was our warmup so all
we need is how we get started all right
I don't know if you need to re-invite me
I don't know there's a there's a lot of
people talk about mafia but we've been
doing seizures I made you - oh hi Blair
browsers already in a party you might
need to leave the current party oh yeah
early access yeah okay I'm free doesn't
know I'm in your party I am leave it
oh well oh right yeah problem exists
between keyboard and chair then the
seizures are definitely my favorite
multiplayer mode the the scale of them
is it's so much fun and just mounting
walls and throwing rocks off the air off
the top of balance so good okay what do
you tend to play this when you like oh I
guess it depends which yeah I like I
like I like being an archer though big
heavy arrows and head shot people are
forces if you can but something like I I
like if we're defending I like kind of
going in through one of the side doors
closing it behind me and then just going
through that back line and spearing all
the trebuchet man oh yeah there's a I
think when an orchard on defense you you
end up getting like quite overconfident
pretty quickly because it's so it's so
hard to hit you and then you you find
out that someone to like carefully
lining its
here well as soon as they breach the
walls you realize I'm not equipped for
close-quarters fighting and now there's
a bunch of angry Vikings that breach the
walls yep
this is a good team out there I love all
the broken walls as well so we are the a
suraíh which means we should have some
decent units yeah if horse archers
they're really good as well oh yeah but
ignore that we said last round was a
warm-up and now we're having another
warm-up but to crave it again more
people should play this video game our
hot 5 damage there it is rough being a
poor search or sometime because it is
it's not easy to land your shots it's
kind of just volume over you have to get
much closer than usual because if you're
going at full speed you have to get
quite close before you actually take the
shot yeah it's almost like a shotgun as
you right
I don't ever wanna tackle oh we're
definitely attacking yaks there the
arrow icons haha tied up you'll be to
read this message I see Brad still loves
his horses they don't really do maybe
like they're good once we get a hole in
the wall and then we can charge through
the m3 line watch more of a continuation
of yeah I can't see them doing the
mother did with previous man blades
where they kind of kotipalli on it this
time around but there's loads of games
have come out since and done the whole
line infantry musket sort of gameplay I
think man page like you know we'll stick
to what we know and do the mad infantry
melee right so what you I was cavalry
but then my horse he did
I decided I'm so bad at playing anything
in this game that doesn't have their
shields well the end the blocking we
have to match the enemies song and I've
done I've done okay and with that sort
of him just I my reaction speeds and
certainly right you're losing all your
gamer cred but you know strategy games
are a for all ages so it'll still have
that they become more cerebral this
cameras doing great I know you mean I've
like I'm 29 next week and I have started
to notice that some of my fps chops are
starting to flag yeah
first-person shooters not frames a
second load a tarkov load of quarter GT
I think it was the four night era that
really drove home how not good at shoot
as I am anymore and you try and play a
game and you're being schooled by kids
that should be in school
it happened to us it'll happen to you
when we're playing Civ 30
and it's only gonna start with some of
the lemon warm-up phase oh we should not
have yeah okay now we will be having a
siege that exactly was a huge time
I'm probably gonna just spawn as some
basic shield inventory and try and get
the siege tower forward okay cool
at least a lot of it I I'm gonna be an
archer it gets cool kills some 360
noscopes I'm just gonna be tribal
warrior because you've got to be brave
to be a skirmisher at this stage he
knows we can also get on the the way the
siege weapons work is really interesting
as well you actually need someone to aim
it someone to range it and someone to
put the the Oh balls in at the bearing
Ram on the right yeah mano on the right
flank with their bearing ram oh I'm all
right and pushing things just watch one
of our guys get Shaunie I hit me yet
no that's another guy for real you mean
like just the awful things yeah I'm also
dead
sorry we got we look how far we got the
air what's it called Ram the siege Tower
is nearly up there as well
what's their situation without shoes oh
yeah that's quite a few yeah someone's
on one of the big Hollister as well are
they have they're pushed out to try and
a counter are powers as well hubris of
it hubris
you hate to say it this guy's going to
get clubbed at see
oh they're trying to cut down our tower
yeah I'm gonna need backup at the rock
the left flank yeah this guy's attacking
a siege tower if you immediate just cut
in this guy up okay you you which one of
you push the push the thing a now I'll
shield you you push in I'm in front of
you the shield drive him off the siege
towers up though we've done I'd the
levees done is they've done their job
okay well I'm full of holes
so can we damage this in place yeah they
can knock it down I'm spawning as a
guard
I've got a horse in the 200 Acts is that
yeah they just went up left yeah well
and check on the mid that maybe the
gates might have been breached open them
you know what you check on the mid is if
someone's gonna get through the first
the first points always the hardest
oh jesus there's so many people oh wow I
don't I think the the siege town might
actually need to go forward another inch
maybe for the good okay and I just
dropped my pike no I don't want to be
any person going up with a minute dead
yeah like that that breach of the gate
absolute legend I don't think the
battering rams made it but someone's
left the gate open so I'm going through
Oh as I was behind the barricades all
this was a bad this was a bad oh I'm
locked in there close the gate behind me
this was on a stake my horse is dead oh
that was a that was a very bad idea
all right there's a breach in the right
wall we can try and push through that
with with infantry masses okay I've got
a big bar dish the peasant I'll wait for
you at the front very front barricades
so yeah so on the very right which one I
use is you know that's thing up and down
where we now switch the defense and we
which yeah we should do because like the
best you know what I don't know
I know it's kicked us out maybe that was
the end I will find another one it's
even when you lose that that game modes
very very dumb fun mmm-hmm yeah in this
single-player it just sort of keeps
going on till one side is dead basically
yeah I don't know if I've played this
map oh no if I have yeah on the right
you can sally out if you're a cavalry
yeah oh so one defense this time know
you love to see it you do you can get
all the six shots but the Berserker is
very fun though in this um yeah and this
fashion
oh this is that this happens sometimes
but with that it's the same fraction on
both sides oh so it can get a little
messy it's just blue beanie guys versus
other blue baby guys friendly fire is
done yep it sure is just like in real
war where the horse hits you and you
just fall flat on your ass yeah it's the
sheer weight of the pony and knocks you
off
so what do you have anymore I think
we've got some content - going up over
the weekend but yeah as far as I know
this is because those you know those in
the US have got their I somehow forgot
the name of the holiday even though it's
just a date so there's the holiday on
4th of July the 4th what's it called I
suppose we can't complain we've got he
got bank holidays didn't realize that
that was a like a British centric thing
thanks banks appreciate it
David I've got stuck between a small
letter and a big pile of mud where are
you it's just like force - it's like if
someone killed me peace and you raise
the ladder and climate oh one of those
pesky fake ladders I just I just caught
a glimpse in the in the death cam like
in the earth it's early access right
now Independence Day is the name of the
movie god someone's gonna realize that
not gonna realize that's a joke and I'm
gonna look like an idiot all right I'm
going as M berserk no brigand a brigand
I think is is better with a lot with a
large shield tree yourself where are you
yeah come to the right side and we'll
push this siege tower oh yeah oh yeah
your name's you're on the left flank I'm
on the right let's sit here and push
this towel I'm plate objective
the siege tower I can see your name in
the distance on the left link there he
goes bless me and I can't see I'm on the
right I'm that if you look for the big
wooden tower that's slowly approaching
across the battlefield that's me I'm
glad oh there we go
it's just you yes literally just me the
hen just man in existence as guys
there's enemies ahead of us as well that
have come out of the castle I'll just
let the team deal with those some sure I
don't think we're like judging by our
past performance we're more like oh it's
always just up oops or large is this is
Hugh okay so I can I can I can hold a
shield up in front of you there's a lot
of lights and you guys push how did that
spear not hit yeah a bit puh oh you got
one pass me shield I'm gonna become a
berserker that's the most fun class for
this region
just big silly acts we appreciate all
the donations coming in as well by the
way chat it's very kind of you if you
want to support the to good causes that
we are doing our best spot right now
then the links are as below or in the
description so spare what you can to
support these fine folks while we try
and what we try and take a castle and
get shot by arrows yeah that's me
crossbow to the face circus you either
in this life here the berserk or the
bouzouki I'm afraid yes I can't tell
who's who
we're all just blue barbarians life
comes at you faster I spawned as this
guy and I didn't realize he didn't have
a shield no I'm a Raider
I think but all the way around the
castle trying to sneak in there's no
entry it's like a ladder here but I
can't get it up
because I'm gonna get shot by arches
only a few shields like yeah well you
make a good point out scraps
ow my the only person that that does
that it has something wrong with their
brain but when they get hurt in a video
game I go out that game doesn't make you
feel it oh I was just about to pick up a
shield and I got domed I'm gonna keep my
eyes open for you in the battlefield oh
yeah I see on the right you might notice
I've got a few arrows tis about a flesh
wound
oh yes cowards they knew it happened
that's why yeah excuse me coughing howdy
hey it's a okay mistake to make you're
not the only one but last time I checked
Chris Pratt probably wasn't very good at
mountain blade bana Lord's so Bennett
then I think we're the real winners I
shut the gate don't shut the gate Oh
cheeky little head shot
yeah again similar to the lessee I feel
like this stage was all just a bunch of
people running around we're going
through the gates really yeah and I mean
people are dropping rocks on us from
above but if the first gate is broken
open we now just need to hack open the
air okay we're in the forlorn hope out
definitely anyone signed off my shields
and a heavy axe come on man what can I
get the horse through oh my days I got
through the forlorn hope and oh boy was
it four lon yes eater see just great
Tyson big fantasy JH this is definitely
bigger time though now we got the F flag
it's like halfway through the castle
someone's Omega gig absolutely flanked
and outmaneuvered Oh F flags on the left
that's why I'm climbing a ladder on the
left oh there's a bunch of ass stuck on
the ladder Oh guys guys definitely dead
I hope someone's below me I'm gonna back
me up so I'm about to get pinkish in V
arches here all right we've taken the
ladder oh wow this guy's is definitely
gonna get crunched yeah you better run
egg but we are up the up the tower up
the ladder and in the Bass Pro is about
to hit a skid it might pull some people
off the main gate and let us say it out
oh I'm in but I don't think it's going
to go well for me my horse is about to
be deceased and as which side through
the seats there on the right we just
move straight in how come that way yeah
they uh they shot my horse and then as
soon as I'd fallen to the ground
that was that was seemed like their cue
to shoot arrows into my body yeah
they'll do that it will vary in consider
a team can climb in the siege tower I
can see your name bobbing up and down
I'm assuming you're doing work yep oh
wait wait on the walls we're taking the
right snowballs
this is going surprisingly all right
you'd love to see it oh one of their
catapults is broken that's a good sign
I realized I was really doing my game of
face thing yeah my tongue sticks out
when I really concentrate on a video
game I see you I see you throwing
supportive spears
hit him for you really yeah yeah I'm
right next to you
let's have him oh is this that was just
king still alive there we go
now he's now he's deceased really
struggling to tell who's on our team
oh they're about to break my shield
oh yeah that's me dead you right
coughing there's a there are some folk
that are incredible at this game and
they just listen to block everything
thrown of them some people that
understand how to actually aim and bow
and arrow as well this is my horse now
[Music]
I was giving them out let me up the
ladder or scout the we're going on the
left there's a guy about to stab me the
bum tried to climb away I had to kill my
own horse it wouldn't block the ladder
I am backed up back to the siege tower
hundred percent there got a few flags
left though it's still 17 minutes in the
siege pretty sure real-life sieges
lasted a little longer if they went well
it is
it's all just kicking off you are you
still on the walls yeah I'm just trying
to get around to the gatehouse Oh Trent
look for Dame's and Archer tried to axe
me never mind someone something killed
him for me from this range there really
is no aiming these javelins you just
just throw and hope for the best kicked
off the favorites you notice when you're
inside like a building this game yeah so
you don't and there's the whole thing
where if you're if your axe hits the
walls you swing that's it you flying off
the wall and you're wide open
most oh poor salad I'm just gonna ignore
him I've got bigger barbarians to skewer
if I can get through his battering ram
kind of wish it could be destroyed just
so he can it's out of the way oh that
was that was you are who's charging T
where are we going yes yeah we're bit
through that back line and I go go for
Dean kill this out from the way
as a treat I there's some like you
deserve it yeah an oblivious Archer is
definitely the treat for breaking
through we are all over deep like easy
easy red easy siege oh oh these are too
many lads these are too many lads my
shields about to fall apart oh never
mind my skull fall apart I'm playing
it's Berserker bite just keep trying to
grab a shield to have on your back just
makes me feel slightly better my neck
imagine I can imagine why it would
although the two-handed axe is where
it's out yeah it's just nice to have you
back of it it's like four four of us
Berserker just climbing a ladder towards
D now someone is in for a very bad time
until we get headshot by heavy arrows
I thought they're really holding a
cioppino that gave me in this wrist
there's forlorn hope version 2.00 wow I
got one shot by that big axe they don't
really need to just concentrate on one
area I guess I think the main gate is
open now
no I mean into the like entity
oh gee I have no idea
you might just have to push since I've
got a heavy horse I might be able to
just charge through well there on the
left yeah there's good away through on
the left there's enough like it alright
yeah we've taped up all his paints
mm-hmm oh wow is a meat grinder in here
I'm through but I don't know how good
it's gonna do me
Jesus card even hit this guy no it's a
bit cramped but we're getting gee I
don't even know if at anyone I was
swinging out was an enemy there it
doesn't matter this thing just keeps
there just like 20 of us or shielded in
the middle of the flag like how do you
how do you beat that without like a hand
grade is that seed Rover - hold on hold
on yeah I'm gonna frying up some of
these arches off the top I got a
berserker coming down the stairs after
you
just watching the carnage from up top
I killed myself I wasn't the wisest
thing I've ever done I tried to get like
a cool shot of me jumping from the
battlements down all right I'm stuck in
the dungeon how do I get out I don't do
is that come on now I got the right way
I walked all the way out back outside
because my physics like how did this guy
get a horse through here I brought my
horse pre-read I saw a guy bring us
horse through the dungeon yeah in the
stairs what that respect that Christian
Christian what you're doing me by that's
a horse Lord I'm still going the wrong
way
Christian seems to know where he's going
though no maybe he doesn't I love that
someone sings urk G oh yes
oh that sneaky are just shooting our
back lines he's known me a very day yeah
ceej kind of gets away from you huh ah
up stray horse just knocks me down
[Music]
hopefully I can go the right direction
this time what you were you playing with
Masuka and a crunch some axes in half
although considering we're in a choke
point may not be the best idea now I
think about it I can't afford a horse I
can literally only spawn as a warrior
I've lost all my gold
stop Pike Python a bad attitude
maybe we don't need maybe we need to
round up some yeah there's some people
in shack trying to get semblance and
team work going on but I think we are
just in the melee phase of the battle
come on airing Rams useless at this
point if anything it's just slowing us
down from getting back into the frame Oh
looks like weird recapturing G though
push on forth so you kids pulling it
this Pike isn't doing what I want it to
do I don't know if there's a steam stove
for this actually um I think it's again
that comes on sale pretty frequently
still I mean it's still in development
it would it would surprise me if it
didn't pop up at this steam summer sale
that's for sure
don't take that as me have insider
information it's entirely a guess yeah
if I was mr. tail world's then I've fun
nesting so she can't I can't get any
momentum going my poor fur hat warrior
just keeps getting hopelessly crunched
six minutes all the time in the world
cloud9 I'm so embarrassed
hubris oh there's these aren't my
friends the right the right flank is
basically a no-go
well there is another way
yeah when you through the gate with the
shield or for that basically five yeah
at which you inside I'm stuck in spikes
I don't think there's any any worry of
me going anywhere
oh now I've unstuck can't go anywhere
without being hit with her arrows where
is this mythical ladder arches decided
to kill me and he is victorious I got
one hit and I got overconfident I don't
see us getting back in five minutes mate
we've actually we've got G we've got G
we just need the whole G now that's
right
okay in there in there like swimwear as
my friend Oscar - used to say I never
understood what he meant by that but it
lives on
they'll have people that the enemy are
jumping off the walls to get to us now I
mean it give me a big ax it'd be so much
easier if we were two different
fractions and s that you're killin
people though I can see popping up in
the feed doing better than I am yeah I'm
at least 70% sure they're on the other I
just saw that as a kill for eight was
like yep that's a let's username well
that's embarrassing dreams are good G
again I've seen I see the ladder I see
the ladder I'm going for it okay I
believe in you you me you may do what I
mean I can't even believe it
F on the ladder yet getting shot with
arrows from above yeah no just looking
than the ladder with a longbow and he's
I can have a shield now have a shield is
a treat
stop hitting my horse I had to pay for
this my hard-earned gold Wow
he just won eight he axed me that's my
first unit that wasn't a warrior in like
five minutes he's dead okay I think
we'll finish this siege and then I think
that'll do us
oh there's a pre action the father you
meet me axe it's rubbish spear say I'm
just going in the fray
whatever will be will be here's the half
of them of the enemy who just can't tell
I'm just gonna stop click in as fast as
I can
get the enemy flag it's working it's
sort working I keep hitting like corpse
is the are on our last star this is it
death or glory final push and I'm stuck
trying to climb a ladder pee on a
bazooka
[Music]
please please we're doing a charity
stream
why weren't you berserkers listen it's
for a good cause
I'm just running through those guys
maybe they'll forget that no you hate to
see it well at least at least boss baby
will live on in legend even if we won't
yeah our boss baby not affiliated with
green words pictures oh thank you so
much hangin out Chris and thank you in
Rio champ for priority support and your
donations and hanging out with us we've
still got loads more coming up for play
for also we're gonna be here for a long
long time we've got lots of exciting
stuff so make sure you stick around and
yeah thanks for joining us have a great
weekend look after yourselves really
soon that person that's in chat I don't
know exactly the time but really yeah
you guys in chat seen to have summoned
the Mafia trailer so go enjoy that and I
will see you the next dream goodbye ever
off